what's up boys and girls it is Gerry I
just came out of a screening the raid -
and electric Boogaloo and holy [ __ ] yeah
man I want to say about this movie I'm
trying to process this as quick as I can
at least just to give you you know the
first impression to get a sense for what
the raid 2 is you know it's like take
the first one and multiply it by 20 it's
like everything is really cranked to 11
in this film it's just good wishes it's
a very different movie
it's almost opposite in a lot of ways
because the first movie is sort of a
great demonstration of how much you can
do on a tight budget with some creative
choreography the raid redemption is sort
of like an exercise in excellence in
simplicity almost it's like the fights
are creative and intricate but the movie
itself is very simple it's very
immediate and the raid 2 basically shows
what Gareth Evans and his crew are
capable of when given all the toys it
seems like and it's certainly a rousing
result this movie is nearly twice as
long as the original film it goes a lot
of different places in terms of location
and story you gotta pay attention
especially to the subtitles because it's
easy to miss certain details and this
plot is a lot more complicated Rama is
now doing undercover work to expose you
know the crooked cops who are making it
possible for these powerful mob families
to control this area of Indonesia
there's a lot going on and it's easy to
get lost if you're a little overwhelmed
there are more colorful characters in
this movie and obviously the fight
scenes are brilliant I mean there is so
much fighting in this movie you could
argue that maybe some of the fights
aren't as easy to sort of justify with
story points but there is so much
creativity and you know it is sort of
the language of this world
is violence and this this film will make
you cringe it'll make you wince you know
there are a couple of fights that got
applause it's tense it hurts
they really thought like what else can
we do there's a car chase in here that
feels less like a car chase it more like
a martial arts fight of some sort and
it's really hard to ever point at one
particular moment where like that's how
great you know that's the pinnacle of
the action in this movie because there's
just so many things to look at the guy
who plays Rama is back as you know our
sort of central character I'm sorry I
don't remember a lot of the names
unfortunately but the focus is a little
more divided this time around because
the the scope is so much bigger it's
like you're not confined to one tenement
block anymore it's cities and ballrooms
and clubs and and like it's really deep
into the more sophisticated part of the
underworld and it's it's insane and
there's some incredible cinematography a
lot of stuff is done in long shots it's
not that sort of edited in a blender
thing that a lot of our action movies
tend to do it's interesting to watch
Gareth Evans grow as a filmmaker because
this movie seems to have taken what he
learned doing the raid and then what he
must have learned doing his segment for
VHS which is fantastic and could be a
film on its own there's no found footage
in this movie but I got a sense that
maybe some of that choreography in terms
of shot design probably came into play
you know there's a big fight in a mud
pit with tons of people and that scene
comes across as though it's one or at
least a few very long takes you know I I
definitely got the sense that maybe
doing that VHS segment probably informed
his bag of tricks I guess you would say
so yeah this is a first impression Ryan
and I think Sally and I were going to
sit down and talk about this later but
um if you liked the raid you'll like
this one
it's a crime epic it's nuts it's off the
wall you know totally it's you know it's
just as gritty it's just as heavy as the
first movie was you know obviously
there's a little bit
here and there but you know everything
is cranked that much bigger and there is
that sense of like a lot of these people
would be dead but Rama is a tank so what
can you do but yeah there are some
amazing fights in this movie there is
some great cinematography there's a more
whiny intricate story going on a broader
scope it's it's pretty killer
right now I'm it's fantastic
you can I'm stuttering a lot so I'm
having trouble you know putting into
words but yeah definitely man if you
like action cinema if you like the raid
go go now don't find it fly to New York
or LA and then see this movie and yeah
that's that's it for the moment so let's
talk an action cinema what's your
favorite action flick what are you some
of your favorite fight scenes hit up the
comments box and as always you know like
subscribe all that good stuff and until
next time folks
so the raid - Cheers
later on